από από την ήγηση ν από το κράτος και αυτή δίνεται θα δούμε όμως χρειάζεται
και αυτή τη στιγμή νομίζω εγκρίθηκε και το η δημειουργεία του εθνικού φορέα για των
καρκίνω γοινών και θετικά βήματα πρέπει να γίνουν ακόμη περιστώλνα υποστηρικτούν ακόμε περιομο δίίνεται μια
καλύπασα γιατρα για να σας ρωτήσε πως βλέπετε αυτό που θέλει να κάνει το κράτος
η κυβέρνηση να φέρει νέα μι αλά νέουςε επιστήμονες πίσω στη χώρα μας όπως δήποτε
να έρθουν νέοι επιστήμονες είναι κάτι πολύ θετικόι ερώτησης είναι πρώτον εαν υπάρχουν πρέει να
δημεοργήσουμε υποδομές να τος φέρουμε εκεί που είναι έφυγαν γιατί βρήκαν υποδομές και έενα το
προειναι να τους φέρουμε αλλά με τι υποομές δεύτερον αρκετί επιστήμονες πάρα πολύ ήρθαν και
επλησίασαν και τα πανεπιστή μα ήρθαν στα πανεπιστή μιά μας στο δικών μας καιντρον έχουμε
σημαντικότενων αριθμόν από μια λλά τα οποία είχαν καριέρα στο εξωτεριών και ήραν και είναι
τώρα και αργάζονται στο γερμανικό αυτή δε θα νιώθουν αδικιμένοι όταν δουθόύν κίνητρα για να
έρθουν άλλοι και αυτί που ήρθα μάλιστα ήρθε σε μια περίοδον που ικύπρος ήταν μέσα
στην κρίση και ήρθαν και σήκωσαν τα μανί γιατίι βοήθησαν αυτή δεν πρέπει να ληφθεί
η υπόψη εν πρέει άλεφθόν υπάψη αράες αυτή κίνησε έχει και τα θετικά αλλά ίσως
να έχει και περισεότερα αρνητικά κίταξε ναδιταιεγώτω εκλαμβάνω ότι βλέποντας τους συναδέλφους χουν κάποιον παράπονα
ναγιατί δεν είχαν τη ανάλουγη ναναγνώριη δεν τι χάνουν της αναγνώησης και το ττο επόμενον
είναι δεν ημονών θα κερδήσουμε είναι